Next question, please comment on the recent news about a
chrylamide in coffee causing cancer.
Well, of course, if you've watched it in the news, California
in their brilliant legislature act have made coffee companies
like Starbucks and Caribou, I don't think they have those out
there, but people conveyors of coffee to have a warning label
on their coffee that coffee causes cancer.
Well, a chrylamide is what is formed from foods typically
carbohydrates, very complex carbohydrates,
when you heat them up.
So yes, there are chrylamides that are formed when you heat
beans up, coffee beans up, and you will form some chrylamides.
Of course, if you look at a chart of what actually forms the
most chrylamides, potato chips is up here, but in their
legislative brilliance, I don't think they are putting
wordy labels on potato chips.
Isn't that funny because those companies are bad people by
muds and who are something?
I don't know, maybe.
French fries, look at the chrylamides that can be formed with
French fries, soup mixes, snack foods, chocolate products,
crackers, nuts and nut butters, bakery and bakery products.
Well, coffee is way down here.
Why are they making them label coffee products?
Because they're a bunch of idiots.
I don't know.
I didn't say that.
Take that back.
I'm sorry.
But it's insane.
So yes, do chrylamides, could they be cancer-causing?
Things?
Well, in truth, if you inject lab
both with any high concentration of any chemical,
they're probably going to form cancer.
Well, why did they ignore all the millions of studies that are
out there about herbicides and roundup?
And you don't have to label that at all.
And you don't have to label GMO products at all.
But you label because of a possible of chrylamide
connection with coffee and cancer.
I'm sorry, but did my test eat it?
Of course, I only have had 500 cancer patients,
but that nobody's had cancer because of a chrylamide.
So it's just ridiculous.
The amount of things that we're exposed to on a daily basis,
this is a minor player compared to this kind of stuff
that's going on.
But because these guys control and pay off the legislature,
these guys can do anything that they want.
And Monsanto basically runs this blasted country.
So yeah, I'm a little bitter, I guess, about that,
because we just see it too often.